[Música]
nuevo bloque de economía en directo
américa ya nuevamente conmigo en el
estudio jorge hurtado jorge vamos a
iniciar hablando de las posibles
sanciones contra rusia en caso de una
invasión a ucrania así de raúl y es que
una de las posibles sanciones que se
barajaban era sacarlos del sistema
financiero global swift aunque esto fue
descartado recientemente antes de
continuar las transacciones swift es la
base del sistema financiero global yo
usan 11.000 bancos en 200 países o
territorios para poder hacer
transferencias internacionales y pensé
que sacar a rusia de este sistema en
caso de agredir a ucrania era parte de
las medidas que se barajaban desde hace
semanas la casa blanca dijo que ésta no
estaría dentro de las posibilidades de
sanciones tales sin quienes el asesor
adjunto de seguridad nacional del
presidente estadounidense joe biden
comentó que todas las opciones siguen
sobre la mesa pero probablemente no
verán su hija en el primer paquete de
sanciones aunque el funcionario no dio
detalles de las sanciones que contemplan
comentó que el costo de invadir ucrania
sería inmenso para rusia tanto para su
economía como para su posición
estratégica en el mundo y seguimos con
más información porque inició en captar
la conferencia regional sobre el gas
jorge le pregunto que se está
discutiendo allí bueno uno de los
principales puntos a discutir es cómo
hacer frente a la demanda global de gas
y también el conflicto entre rusia y
ucrania el lunes comenzaron las
reuniones a nivel ministerial de los
expertos del foro de países exportadores
de gas que cuenta con 11 miembros
mientras que este martes se reunirán los
jefes de estado y de gobierno el
presidente iraní ebrahim raisi llegó a
doha en la primera visita de un
presidente iraní a qatar en 11 años y
mientras los estados del golfo observan
las conversaciones indirectas entre eeuu
seguirán para salvar el pacto nuclear de
2015 en el grupo de países hacen parte
rusia qatar irán libia argelia y nigeria
que juntos representan el 70% de las
reservas probadas de gas en todo el
mundo y en centroamérica el presidente
de el salvador hablamos de la buque le
anunció reformas legales en materia
económica jorge cuáles son estas así es
y bueno lo hizo como siempre a través de
un tweet mencionó que enviará al
congreso una cincuenta y dos reformas
para eliminar los trámites reducir la
burocracia crear incentivos fiscales y
aunque no precisó
reformas están relacionadas con el
bitcoin que fue adoptado como moneda
legal en septiembre del 2021 prometió
que convertirá el salvador en un refugio
para la libertad el fondo monetario
internacional pidió el gobierno de el
salvador limitar el alcance de la ley
bitcoin eliminando su condición de
moneda de curso legal y mostró
preocupación por la emisión de bonos
respaldados con la cripta moneda para
marzo raúl se espera que el gobierno
salvadoreño emita bonos por 1.000
millones de dólares en bitcoin la
agencia de medición de riesgo fitch
ratings rebajó la calificación
crediticia a largo plazo del salvador
entre las razones dijo que hay
incertidumbre de alcanzar un acuerdo con
el fondo monetario internacional claro y
ahora seguimos hablando de cripto
monedas pero en méxico así así es que la
fiebre del bitcoin está impulsando
varios modelos de negocios en torno al
cripto activo en méxico crearon el
bitcoin en base a un bar que busca
acercar este modelo de transacciones
comerciales a todo el mundo y empoderar
con conocimiento gratuito sobre las
cripto monedas el bar que está ubicado
en el céntrico barrio de la roma méxico
muestra advertencias sobre el fraude y
estanterías llenas de libros sobre el
ecosistema de cripto monedas según la
empresa finder' méxico ocupa el lugar 14
de 27 países estudiados en cuanto a la
oposición de estos activos
que las personas se acerquen a la comuna
las personas se acerquen a los
conocimientos
y que no se dejen llevar tanto por el
fondo por esta euforia que causan a
veces el mercado que realmente se
preocupen por entender qué es lo que
están haciendo antes sí quieran y que
hay que ir hacia de méxico es así la
encantadora jorge para poder reformar
una cripto cerveza un cryptography vamos
a ver qué pasa entonces indicado el
jorge e iniciamos en asia las acciones
asiáticas moderaron pérdidas tras
conocerse una posible cumbre entre eeuu
y rusia propuesta por francia las
acciones europeas limitaron sus
ganancias iniciales con los valores
tecnológicos liderando las pérdidas por
las tensiones respecto a europa del
extra
bueno cripto amigo gracias entonces por
toda la información económica por eso
mañana con más información nos vamos
directo a parís ya está lista natales
con toda la información de francia
[Música]